just from the eye test it looks like
things aren't coming as
easy for you this year is that a safe
way to look at it that thing i feel um
you know it's a lot of it's a lot of
schemes you know we're going to get
defenses um they calling out our plea
stuff like that like they know what
we're doing so
a lot of that you know sometimes you
know stuff won't go our way
if they beat this to the punch so you're
you're hearing on the other side of the
line of scrimmage the defense
calling out your place yeah they
definitely do like run
stuff like that or watch out for this
watch out for that sometimes that's
what's going on
so how do you how do you combine that
lamar so
we i guess we're going to have time and
let coach you know
let us know what he sees upstairs and we
just go from there
samar jackson with rich eisen earlier
today that is never good
when your offense is sufficiently
predictable that through film
study the opposing defense knows what
you're going to do it's incumbent on an
offensive coordinator
to change things up to run different
plays out of different formations
and that's what defensive players always
do they study the film
they look at the alignment they look at
the way people stand they look for
anything and everything that's part of
this where's waldo exercise
that i find fascinating one of the great
players in nfl history at spotting stuff
like that is chris spielman i've talked
to him about that before
he would find the dumbest little tells
that would let him know what's going to
happen when the ball is snapped and if
the defense has that just
even if it's run versus pass doesn't
have to be where the ball is going to go
just run versus pass if you know that's
coming you've got a huge edge over the
offense and it sounds like greg roman
needs to get back to the laboratory and
come up with some different formations
or different looks to disguise pre-snap
what the play is going to be shireen how
many phone calls do you think lamar
jackson has gotten
from greg roman and john harbaugh
today i think he's probably heard from
all of those people that what are you
talking about
what are you saying uh but yes they
they definitely if they're that
predictable they need to figure
something out i mean this is the offense
that was
basically the same as last year and they
were first in scoring in second in yards
last season and they can't seem to
figure that out for whatever reason they
just
haven't been the same offense and lamar
jackson hasn't been the same
quarterback and and yet marshalliando
was really the only big change the
offense so
i don't get why they haven't produced
but that certainly would explain it if
people have figured out
what they're doing it's possible they're
just so good and so talented they can
get away with some of that
because even if you know what they're
doing good luck stopping it
but it is alarming and it it may cause
the ravens to think twice about setting
up these interviews for lamar jackson
because you got to be careful the things
you put out there but the bottom line is
they know we know everyone knows the
ravens have an issue now when it comes
to
getting these these plays sufficiently
diversified the formations changed up
the predictability gone otherwise the
defense is gonna know what's coming and
then you have a major problem when it
comes to trying to move the ball
especially against a great team and
they've got
a problem recently shireen with great
teams
and it's going to be exacerbated when
it's time to try to win in the playoffs
because they're going to have plenty of
pressure because they're 0-2 under lamar
jackson
yeah they're six and two right now mike
and no doubt headed to the postseason
but does anybody look at them as a super
bowl contender at this point
i mean their third or fourth you start
ranking those teams that have a chance
they're not one of the top two teams you
start talking about they have to figure
this out and they've got
the patriots this week the titans next
week and then the steelers on
thanksgiving night so some
challenges coming up for the baltimore
ravens
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports